hello my friends this is Steve the
linguist on language talking about
language as usual
today I want to talk about something I
just found on the Internet I discovered
a phenomenon called Tim Ferriss that's
the person's name he's written a book
which I can show you here the 4-hour
workweek which is a bestseller number
one bestseller on The Wall Street
Journal and he is someone who you know
is an adventurer and he speaks lots of
languages and he does martial arts and
dances tangos and travels the world he I
was made aware of him because someone
told me that he had posted a blog post
on language learning which have been
very successful thousands of people had
you know dig dig did and so it was very
successful of dig so I went and had a
look and and basically what the the
article says is that and what his claim
is that you can learn any language in
one hour in one hour and as you read
through it you realize that that's not
at all what the body of the message is
about but he sure attracts attention and
I think I should start saying you'll
learn any language in ten minutes what
does it matter ten minutes one hour and
he says before you invest or waste
hundreds and thousands of hours on a
language you should deconstruct it
whatever that means and but as you go
through it you discover that what he
really is saying is that within an hour
you can find out if that language is
easy or difficult for you and that
process takes an hour so that's a little
different from what the title of the
piece says but even there most of the
information he provides to me is either
inaccurate or misleading of course the
title is misleading learn it in an hour
in an hour and then he says things like
you know find out which language sounds
like yours so if you're Japanese
you should learn Spanish and you'll have
a difficult time learning Chinese well
that's not necessarily Seoul Chinese is
difficult because of tones but a
Japanese person has a lot of vocabulary
going into Chinese which he wouldn't
have in Spanish and the fact that it's
easier to pronounce
some people are good at pronunciation
others aren't generally speaking people
who are good at pronouncing one second
language are good at pronouncing other
second languages so to me that is quite
misleading and it would suggest that a
Spanish person would have an easier time
learning Japanese which where the sounds
the vowel sounds at least are very
similar to Spanish then let's say French
where the vowel sounds are difficult
different well in fact that's not true a
Spanish person will learn French very
easily and will not learn Japanese very
easily he was on to say you know analyse
the grammatical structure whether it's
subject-verb-object
sv o or s ol v subject-object-verb
and that will determine if it's easy
well that's simply not so I mean German
is subject-object-verb
unlike English or Swedish whereas
Chinese is subject-verb-object
but a so each person will have an awful
lot easier time learning German than
learning Chinese you know yeah how
similar the languages aren't obviously
that's gonna help but then it was on to
suggest that that if you study both
Portuguese and Spanish
there will be fate whole he calls them
interference because they're similar
well that's not true there's all kinds
of people who speak three or four
Romance languages and speak them well or
speak two or three Slavic languages and
speak them well so that most of this
quite honestly is just nonsense and he
goes on in great detail about
complicated stuff about ik axillary
verbs and sounds and scripts he goes on
to suggest that a Spanish speaker would
have trouble learning Brazilian
Portuguese because the sounds are so
different well I can tell you as someone
who speaks Spanish and is learning
Portuguese that is simply not so
he says that anyway what it's it's all
nonsense but the interesting thing is
that not much earlier he had another
blog post where he said that it takes
him three weeks to refresh a language
that he's already learned and otherwise
how can he possibly keep up all these
languages well I'm sure he didn't learn
them very well in the first place
because I find I don't really have a
problem that way and he's got a three
week you know program of reading phrases
and stuff all of which I find quite
unhelpful in in my own case if I go to
refresh the language if all of a sudden
I'm called by the local Mandarin Chinese
television station here in Vancouver
that they want me on I listen to Chinese
for a few hours I get out some CDs some
comic dialogues young some dialogue or
I'll you know if I'm you know want to
refresh one of the languages I have
audiobooks in all these languages listen
to them so a lot of nonsense what is
true in there though or let's put it
another way I think what is true is that
the grammatical approach to language
learning is not very effective
so we need some kind of intense
intensive exposure
I think we're worrying about
deconstructing the languages is just a
lot of fluff really to make his post
seem interesting and so that he can make
reference to what he studied that was
Princeton but yes when he in the earlier
post when he talks about wanting to
expose himself to the language to
refresh his brain that is effective and
even starting from scratch if you
emphasize you know exposure to the
language you will do better but overall
if you go back to the basic thrust of
his original the blog post that I went
to look at which talks about learning
language in an hour and then quickly
kind of slides out of that and says
we're really talking about helping you
decide which language to learn if you
want to decide which language to learn
choose a language that you passionately
want to learn that is the overall
consideration if you have a need
to learn English it doesn't matter
whether the English has similar sounds
or similar subject-verb-object structure
in the language if you are a few have a
spanish boyfriend or girlfriend or if
you love the culture of China or Japan
or Russia and if you really connect with
that language from an emotional
passionate point of view you will do
well in that language and some languages
are more difficult and it is certainly
true that the languages and the big
thing to look for is vocabulary the more
similar the vocabulary that easier it
will be because the big battle is
accumulating all the words you need in
order to be able to deal with different
situations and in my case for example
Chinese was very difficult for me
because all of our cabinet or it was new
although Chinese is an easy language to
learn in terms of vocabulary because
it's so systematic the different
components that characters fit together
to you know combined in a compound to
create a new word and very often you can
guess the meaning so but with Chinese
then going into Japanese which is a very
different language structurally it was a
tremendous advantage to me that I was
able to read the characters and I
therefore had an instant vocabulary of
50% of the words of Japanese now when I
went from Japanese to Korean which is
not a language that I don't yet speak
although I have studied it the fact that
its structure the order and the way they
instead of prepositions they have post
positions and so forth that helped me so
similarity in structure helps but
similarity in vocabulary is a much
bigger deal all right
so however Tim Ferriss I gotta hand it
to him I went out and bought his book
you know I kind of flipped through it
it's typical of these self-help books
you can flip through them pretty quickly
but there are some useful you know URLs
there or places to outsource in order to
simplify your life and I am gonna go
back there and do a little more reading
so there you have it my take on Tim
Ferriss